-Welcome. It's so lovely to see
all three of you.
-Hey.
-Thank you.
-So, this is a documentary that
covers how you-all covered
the 2020 primary.
And I imagine, looking back --
Even when I watch any TV now
where people are interacting
with other people,
it gives me anxiety,
but this is actually footage
of you in large groups of people
very recently.
-It's bizarro world, right?
That's what it looks like.
It's this alternate universe
that you kind of remember,
but you don't remember.
Yeah, and I would agree,
and especially when Kaitlan
is standing there
in that huge crowd.
-I know, I know, I know.
-It's like,
"What are you doing?!
Get out of there!"
-And I'm, like,
shaking hands with voters,
and, like, I hug a few people.
And I'm, like, watching it.
I'm like, "I touched someone."
Like, that did
actually happen once.
-Remember how it feels.
-I also want to ask, you know,
when you cover a campaign,
you know, I think that those of
us who watch it
from a distance, we think that
we are in tune with
what the candidates are saying,
but you are hearing,
more often than not,
the exact same
stump speech
over and over again.
Does that -- Does it feel like
"Groundhog Day"?
Is it exactly the same?
-Yes. For the most part, yes.
Donald Trump is
a little bit different.
I mean, he actually does just
kind of do his own thing
most times,
and Kaitlan can tell you that.
But most candidates,
it's remarkable.
I mean,
I've been covering campaigns
on the road since 2000,
and I can still recite
a big part of
Bill Bradley's stump speeches.
I can still recite
John McCain's stump speech
from 2008 because it becomes
like the song in your head
that you hear in the --
and it won't go away.
-And it's really weird,
because you can expect
to hear the joke.
"Oh, here comes that joke for
the 7,000th time.
And there it is."
-I can't imagine anything more
terrifying than knowing
an Amy Klobuchar joke is coming.
-That James Madison joke --
I mean, 700 times.
-Also, I can't imagine a
less sort of necessary
party trick than being
able to recite
Bill Bradley's
2000 stump speech.
"Dana, Dana, you must do this
for everyone."
-It wasn't -- today.
-So, I also want to talk
about -- You know, this is a --
I think a primary
that nobody could predict,
and then, all of a sudden,
after South Carolina,
it just coalesced so quickly
behind Joe Biden,
and you sort of didn't know
what was going to happen.
And then, so quickly, you know,
a state that, you know,
is obviously,
more likely than not,
gonna be Republican state when
it votes in the general,
decided the
path of this primary.
Were you-all surprised,
being out on the road
with these candidates, how
quickly the party coalesced
behind Joe Biden?
-Well, I was traveling with
Amy Klobuchar,
and it was astonishing to see --
You were just talking about
how we memorized
the stump speeches
as they are reciting them.
When she went from saying her
stump speech one day
to flying to Dallas,
to standing next to Joe Biden,
extracting her name
out of that stump speech
that we had all memorized
and inserting Joe Biden's name,
it was that
shocking and stunning.
So it was.
It was incredibly fast and
it happened, it felt, overnight.
-There's certainly been
some analysis --
or, I should say,
some opining --
that this is actually playing to
Joe Biden's favor right now
that he's managing
a campaign of, you know,
due to the restrictions of
the pandemic,
whereas it seems like
these restrictions
are driving the president crazy,
that he is sort of desperate
to be out in front of people.
Kaitlan, I would like to see
if that's your
read on it, as well.
-No, he's, like, going
stir-crazy, basically,
because the president isn't
someone who only campaigns
when he has
an election coming up.
He's been campaigning his
entire presidency.
I mean, we have never really
stopped doing these rallies.
They've amped up sometimes
during around the midterms,
gone down in others,
but we've always had rallies.
And so that's what was a staple
of, obviously, 2016 for him.
And, so, you talk to several
White House officials who say,
you know, "We just got to get
him out of The White House.
Like, even if it's just going
down the street, you know,
to the Veterans Affairs building
or, you know,
anywhere in Washington."
And they just really know that
he needs to get out,
because when he's around people,
it puts him in a better mood.
And when he's just sitting
at The White House,
he goes stir-crazy, and then
that makes his aides --
You know, then they have all of
this list of demands
of things that he wants,
and so they want
the president out on the road.
And so that's something that
they are having to deal with,
and I think we've seen,
you know,
the negative aspects of that.
It was those rallies that he did
hold during the pandemic.
And, clearly,
they've learned their lesson,
and that is not something
that, you know,
they're trying
or even attempting anymore.
-I want to talk about
the fact that, you know --
Dana, I know you've
talked to Dr. Birx.
And, Kyung, I know
you've actually been in
hospitals where people are
treating the virus,
actual medical professionals.
How -- I don't know if
"distressing" is the right word,
but, you know, how different is,
you know, what you're seeing,
Kyung, in actual, you know,
medical facilities
and what you're hearing
from Dr. Birx?
Like, is it frustrating that you
can't get a straight answer
from this administration?
And how different
is their answer
from what you're seeing
on the ground?
-I just came back from
El Centro, California,
where there's a disproportionate
number of Hispanic patients.
It is a town that is 80% Latino.
It is impoverished.
And if you look at
what this entire community
is going through,
where there's a call,
an emergency COVID call,
for the fire department
every 30 minutes,
and then you listen to one
meeting out of The White House
or one press conference,
it has no connection to what
we are seeing on the street.
It has no relevance to the
doctors who we're interviewing,
to the patients who are
connected to ventilators,
to the hospitals
who are treating people
in military tents
on American soil.
So it feels --
You were just talking about
bizarro world, right?
We look back
at this documentary,
and it feels like
a million years ago?
It feels -- Trying to cover
this story today,
it feels like
bizarro world right now.
-And somebody like Dr. Birx --
the reason why I think
the interview became such
a thing is because
she was speaking honestly
and she was trying to
sound the alarm in a way that we
haven't really heard from her.
We've heard it from Dr. Fauci
in layman's terms,
which is why he's become
America's doctor, right?
Because he speaks English in a
way that people can understand.
Dr. Birx is more of
a statistician,
and so that's the way she
started to talk,
but then kind of got her
to the point where
she laid it out, saying that
we are in a new phase,
that the Midwest is in
a very dangerous position.
And, Seth, you know,
after that, the president
got really mad at her
because she was laying out
the truth, as opposed to
laying out the reality
that the president
is trying to create for people.
-Do you sort of feel like,
when you're interviewing her,
you can see, in real time,
as she does that calculation of
knowing there are
really important things to say
and then what will be
the fallout
from The White House
because she said it?
-Yeah.
I mean, yes, that happens.
I mean, you see it
and hear it from her.
Fauci actually sometimes
just articulates like,
"I'm not going to say it exactly
the way you were asking me
because I can't
give you the sound bite.
That will -- everything."
He actually says it.
The fine line they walk
is something
that I don't think
any of us could even imagine.
-Kaitlan, you got to ask
the president --
and I'm sure when you were
coming up as a cub reporter,
this was the sort of question
you hoped you'd get to ask --
about a doctor he was touting
who, among other things,
has also talked about alien DNA.
And, well,
I guess my question is,
when you ask a question
like that, how --
I mean, you must have to be
careful in the phrasing
to make sure that people know
you're actually talking about
a real thing.
-No, and you do and you never
would imagine asking that.
And I even left out
the most scandalous parts
of this woman's,
you know, dissertation
that she's put online,
talking about demon sex,
talking about these things
that I actually looked into them
and read and listened to
her sermons that she had given,
because I wanted to make sure
I fully understood
what she was saying
and that it wasn't being
taken out of context.
And it wasn't.
But the question is,
how do you sum that up
to make it a question
in the briefing room?
And you saw
how the president responded.
I mean, he clearly wasn't aware
of this woman's
statements before.
But then, even after we had told
him what she had said, you know,
he stood by her
and he continued to elevate her.
And it's just --
It's a remarkable moment
when you're in a pandemic
and we've had
so many moments where --
I was in the briefing room when
the bleach/disinfectant
suggestion came up
from the president.
You've been there at other times
when he's left the Rose Garden
on us because he didn't like
our questions.
But I think, truly,
that this took the cake,
having to ask the president
about a woman
that says she thinks they're
trying to come up with
a vaccine so people
won't become religious.
-And while I admire your
restraint in not bringing up
the demon sex, I want you to
know that we covered it --
We covered it more than anybody
could have possibly wanted.
-I'm sure you did us proud.
-You know, obviously,
going into this primary,
it was as diverse a field
as we've seen
from any major political party.
You know, we obviously ended up
in a place where, you know,
for lack of a better term,
we have, you know,
a couple of elderly,
distinguished
white gentlemen as our nominees.
But, you know, the other thing
that comes across
in the documentary is the --
You know, the reporters
who cover these things have --
are more diverse
than ever before.
Can you guys just speak to,
you know,
how important that is
to have it viewed through
a different spectrum
than just, you know,
white male, you know,
news reporters?
-Oh, I think that,
just real quickly, I mean,
if you look at this report that
just came out yesterday,
the number of women
who are running for Congress
who are women of color
is three times the number
that it was in 2016.
So the people
who are running for office,
who want to represent
this country, look different,
and the press
has to look different.
And Dana has been doing this
a whole lot longer than I have
in the political space,
and, I mean, she's seen it,
in real time, change --
right? --
from the boys on the bus to now
many more girls on the bus.
And that includes girls
of color, like me.
So it's -- It is changing
and it has to change
because America's changing.
-Yeah, that's exactly
what I was going to say.
I was going to say, I'm the
grizzled veteran of this trio,
and I can't tell you
how different it looks --
not just on the stump, but in
the press pen,
because it was
really mostly dudes
when I first started.
There were some women,
but it was mostly men
and mostly white men,
and it has gradually and
slowly changed.
But I think this year, 2020,
it was much more stark
and it had to be to represent
what we were actually
seeing from the candidates.
-Well, I really appreciate
all three of you
making time for us today.
I mean this genuinely.
We could never
do a show like ours
if people like you
weren't out doing your job.
And keep up the great work.
-Thanks for having us.
-Thank you for having us.